notre second débat comme promis un gros
plan sur la situation économique de
notre pays croissance nulle inflation
galopante taux d'intérêt qui remonte les
voyant pas ce talent orange sandra
cerqueira
après une forte reprise en 2021 la
france affiche une croissance nulle à
l'origine de ce mauvais chiffre la
stratégie zéro qu'ovide de la chine et
la guerre en ukraine qui font flamber le
prix de l'énergie et des produits
alimentaires
conséquence l'inflation augmente elle
devrait dépasser les 5% ge et sa
vraisemblablement ça va peser sur le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages parce qu'en
face au fait on voit bien que les
salaires ne suivent pas l'évolution de
l'indicé des prix à la consommation donc
bien sûr il y aura des ménages qui vont
être pénalisés d'ailleurs ils le sont
déjà parce qu'on a vu que au premier
trimestre 2010 22 à la consommation des
ménages a reculé de 1 3% donc déjà il ya
eu ce premier effet la banque de france
freddy de fortes hausses au moins
jusqu'en septembre puis un
ralentissement qui devrait durer
jusqu'en 2024 l'inflation a aussi des
conséquences sur les entreprises car la
hausse des prix de l'énergie fait
augmenter les coûts de production
l'inflation impact aussi les taux
d'intérêt qui conditionne ceux des
emprunts et du crédit on va dire que sur
le plus long terme ça va et vient
ralentir leurs projets d'investissement
puisque ça va devenir une entreprise
moins rentables en tout cas plus cher
d'investir puisque les taux d'intérêt
vont progressivement
augmenter le taux moyen de crédits
proposés par les banques ne cessent
d'augmenter pour atteindre 1 5 % sur 20
ans du jamais vu depuis plusieurs années
pour tenter de freiner l'inflation la
fed banque centrale américaine a
augmenté ses taux d'un demi point
l'objectif est de maintenir
artificiellement bas les taux d'intérêt
pour doper l'économie la banque
d'angleterre a fait de même de quoi
mettre la banque centrale européenne
sous pression
l'économie française qui passe alors en
joie le thème de notre débat avec
anne-sophie l6 bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes chef économiste de bo france eric
heyer bonsoir soit directeur du
département analyse et prévision de
l'eau fp2e raphaël legendre bonsoir
d'artistes à l'opinion et lætitia
koupaki rester à mes côtés
re bonsoir laetitia je commence par la
croissance de sophie elle siffle moteur
il s'arrêtait alors pas arrêté mais en
tout cas grandement ralenti on en
parlait quand on a eu la prise avec le
co vie dans dix ans tout sur la
confiance et c'est vrai qu'avec cette
crise il y avait un côté on attendait le
vaccin et après enfin on pouvait
consommer malgré l'inflation qui s'est
déjà en 2021 on avait une forte
consommation des ménages là c'est vrai
qu'avec et la crise et la hausse des
prix l'énergie et on sait que ça va
durer 1 c'est ça qui change complètement
l'état d'esprit eh bien il ya une
crainte donc on consomme mois et surtout
malheureusement on épargne et c'est ça
ou c'est mauvais puisque on attend une
croissance en tout cas on attendait une
croissance robuste qui se basait
majoritairement sur la consommation eric
aiea ce cas des secteurs qui sont
secteur d'activité qui sont plus touchés
que d'autres par cette baisse de la
consommation alors d'abord il fallait
préciser que même alors quand tout
allait bien pour l'inconnu française
lorsque cette dernière avait rattrapé
son niveau d'avant crise certains
secteurs étaient toujours à la traîne on
pense au métal transport à l'hébergement
la restauration qui tournait encore à
peu près à -20 entre - 18 et moins 25 en
dessous du niveau d'avant crise donc ces
secteurs-là n'avaient toujours pas
retrouvé leurs niveaux de crise alors
pour l'hébergement la restauration et ça
semble aller enfin il ne s'est pas eux
qui vont subir la de deux points fait de
de plein fouet cette crise c'est plutôt
les secteurs industriels parce
qu'effectivement c'est une très forte
augmentation des dés de l'énergie qui va
impacter ces secteurs-là l'industrie et
l'industrie va être aussi impactés par
la stratégie zéro qu'ovide de la chine a
donc attention le problème aujourd'hui
en dehors de l'augmentation des prix
liés à aux conflits ukrainien c'est tout
de même un problème d'approvisionnement
dans l'industrie c'est le frein
principal et dans les services et les
difficultés de recrutement donc y avait
quand même des petites tensions même
avant cette crise alors à cela vient se
rajouter effectivement une baisse de
pouvoir d'achat immédiat parce que ça
touche l'énergie l'alimentaire est donc
là tout d'un coup la consommation sara
lee donc il ya beaucoup de ménages
français qui arbitrent quoi tout
simplement comparé ya beaucoup de
ménages qui arbitrent d'autres qui ont
la chance d'avoir pu sur épargné pendant
la crise vous voyez le bilan aussi de
sept de ses deux ans qu vide c'est qu'un
peu à peu près 160 6 milliards 170 ce
maudit la banque de france parce qu'on
n'est plus à 4 milliards près dans ce
cas de figure de sueur et de sueur et
par n'y a pas de l'épargné de sur
épargne et donc effectivement c'est mais
c'est qui est concentrée sur les 20% des
ménages les plus aisés donc ces derniers
peuvent toujours compenser on allait
puiser là dedans mais les 20% les plus
modestes qui avaient dû désépargner
pendant la crise qu villes qui se
touchent kiki qui se voit directement
impacté par l'augmentation du prix
d'énergie et l'alimentaire boureux les
difficultés sont là on revoit ses
chiffres de l'inflation sur un an au
mois d'avril 4,8 pour cent prévisions
mais 5% prévisions juin 5,4 pour cent
c'est le point de conjoncture de l'insee
si on rentre dans le détail 6 3 pour
l'alimentaire 26 % pour les prix de
l'énergie a fait le gendre on l'a un peu
évoquée mais je vous recommande dans le
détail c'est une inflation qui n'est pas
uniquement liée à la guerre en irak qui
n'est pas uniquement contre ducret
l'avant d'ukraine pardon ça c'est bon
c'est mon côté vieux journaliste en
ukraine qui est plus structurel c'est ça
alors c'est ce qu'on disait
effectivement il ya encore six ou neuf
gagner encore aux six mois l'année
dernière
comme anne sophie l'a rappelé avait déjà
commencé pour le côté côté offre
effectivement il manquait des matériaux
les prix augmentent et on se disait que
ça allait durer un an et que au
printemps 2022 tout irait bien le
conflit ukrainien effectivement a remis
une couche et là on voit que l'inflation
est en train devenir beaucoup plus large
que uniquement sur les produits importés
ou même sur les matières premières et
s'étend notamment à l'alimentation ce
qui va effectivement trappe et très
directement les ménages d'ores et déjà
ça implique des changements dans la
politique monétaire et dans les taux
des banques centrales des états unis
l'ont déjà fait l'inflation a augmenté
plus fort beaucoup plus fort là bas et
donc depuis quelques mois les taux de la
fed sont en train de remonter et là on
est en pleine discussion entre les
membres du conseil des gouverneurs de la
banque centrale européenne pour savoir
si oui ou non il est temps désormais de
remontée des taux pour lutter contre
l'inflation le dilemme est temps que
quand on a eu un coup d'arrêt de la
croissance en france en tout cas au
premier trimestre et que les
perspectives s'assombrissent au fur et à
mesure que la guerre dure et bien c'est
cet arbitrage entre lutte contre
l'inflation et soutien à la croissance
qu'il va falloir trancher vendredi le
gouverneur de la banque de france
françois villeroy de galhau s'est
exprimé très clairement en disant qu'il
était temps dorénavant de faire repasser
les taux en territoire positif c'est à
dire qui a le choix de 21 clubs
l'augmenter pardon nous intéresse mais
quand les états unis font ça est-ce
qu'on a d'autres choix que de les suivre
le découplage est compliqué si vous
voulez on a un dollar qui est
extrêmement fort en ce moment pour
plusieurs raisons la croissance
américaine même s'il ya eu un petit
hoquet au premier trimestre se porte
toujours bien c'est une
valeur refuge le dollar quand on a les
crises ailleurs sur d'autres continents
comme on l'a aujourd'hui en europe et
puis depuis dix ans le dollar est
arrimée au pétrole et au gaz américain
les états unis sont devenus exportateur
net de produits énergétiques gaz pétrole
et donc quand le pétrole augmente et
bien le dollar également
se renforce donc à face à l'euro face à
d'autres monnaies aussi et ça ça a un
impact sur l'économie française aussi
pour toutes les entreprises qui
exportent c'est plutôt bien parce que on
est plus compétitif à l'international
sauf que comme on achète tout en dollars
aux côtés pétrole et énergie ça
renchérit la facture énergétique n'est
donc pas plus tard qu'hier on a annoncé
un déficit commercial de la balance
commerciale en glissement annuel c'est à
dire sur 12 mois à 100 milliards d'euros
ce qu'on n'avait jamais vu en france et
jamais arrivées alors je serai sur
l'inflation avec une réaction celle de
michel edouard leclerc qui se projette
sur les chiffres de la rentrée écoutez
pas 4 8% avant l'ukraine et pourtant par
exemple un doublé et ça va doubler
laissez moi vous le l'anticiper je fais
pas avec plaisir ça va doubler d'ici
l'été ou durant l'été parce que il ya
les halles le problème des céréales avec
l'ukraine le premier transport avec
l'ukraine et puis il ya beaucoup de
spéculations il ya beaucoup
d'anticipation contre laquelle il va
falloir lutter parce que je suis pas sûr
que là dedans il n'est que de la
justification de hausse de prix il ya
aussi des effets d'aubaine pour des
grands groupes de se servir de l'ukraine
alors on va on va pas développer c'est
intéressant mais sur les essais domaine
mais je voudrais plutôt qu'on se
projette sur la réaction du futur
gouvernement on peut dire que en haut de
la pile du futur gouvernement voyant la
question du pouvoir d'achat il ya eu des
promesses qui ont été faites pas
emmanuel macron à ce fiel site est ce
que ça veut dire que le quoi qu'il en
coûte sous d'autres
justification on va forcément continuer
alors ça va sûrement continuer au moins
cette année parce que c'est vrai qu'on
va avoir ses os la grande grande
difficulté c'est vraiment le coup on
s'en souvient plus ça nous paraît très
très grande quand on avait tous et loin
pardon ces débats sur les réformes
fiscales on parlait de baisses d'impôts
jeu pourrait coûter 1 ou 2 milliards le
budget qui vous fait rêver de 2,3
milliards là à chaque fois qu'on fait un
chèque c'est 5 milliards ces 26
milliards le dernier plan de soutien
enfin c'est des sommes qui n'ont rien à
voir en termes de volume et proportions
alors c'est vrai qu'avec le quoi qu'il
en coûte on est un peu anesthésié donc
on a l'habitude chaque semaine d'avoir
des milliards qui sont annoncés mais un
moment et l'année prochaine on va
normalement re devoir passer au pacte de
stabilité de croissance on est dans une
zone euro donc les autres pays n'ont pas
forcément la même vision on est censé
avoir une tendance quand même
d'assainissement parce qu'en tout cas
les politiques on l'a dit monétaire -
sûrement moins accommodante mais
également budgétaire donc là ça va
vraiment être difficile parce que dans
le budget on va avoir une grande partie
de la marge de manoeuvre qui va être
rivés sur cette problématique du pouvoir
d'achat une question et la guerrière sur
sur l'inflation et beaucoup de français
qui demandent des hausses de salaires et
des politiques aussi notamment du côté
de la france à soubise ou de la nouvelle
union populaire économique et social à
la banque centrale européenne met en
garde contre ce que ce que l'on appelle
les effets de second tour alors ça vous
pouvez vous expliquer c'est quoi alors
c'est plus de la politique là pour le
coup c
l'inflation on augmente les salaires
mais ça provoque de nouveaux élus noé
pris ça pour compenser cette baisse du
pouvoir d'achat vous pouvez demander des
hausses de salaires donc du coup c'est
plus le salarié qui encaisse ces
augmentations prix mais c'est votre
employeur et votre employeur qui voit
ses coûts augmenter à la fois les coûts
énergétiques et ses coûts salariaux
qu'est-ce qui fait il augmente ses prix
en augmentant ses prix accord s avouer
donc car ça peut faire des spirales qui
monte jusqu'à 10 15 comme c'était le cas
après chaque choc pétrolier en 74 79 et
ensuite la banque centrale n'ont plus
d'autre choix que d'augmenter les taux
aujourd'hui elles peuvent encore dire
c'est très limité c'est pas de
l'inflation et une inflation pour une
banque centrale s'est tous les prix qui
explosent bon là c'est encore même si un
fall dit un peu tous les prix augmentent
mais c'est quand même essentiellement
énergétique alimentaire s'est pas encore
complètement dans les salaires
contrairement aux etats unis c'est pour
ça que la banque centrale européenne
peut encore dire bon j'y vais mollo dès
que ça va dans les salaires on est
obligé d'augmenter enfin la banque
centrale est obligé de le faire c'est
pour ça que le gouvernement se dit je ne
peux pas à face je vais j'essaie
d'éviter cela d'accord mais je veux pas
une trop grande perte de pouvoir d'achat
et donc je vais aider les ménages pour
qu'il ne se retourne pas auprès de leur
employeur c'est beaucoup par coup quoi
alors luz voilà ce qu'on aimerait mais
ça a été déjà dit mais que ça soit du
quoi qu'il en coûte messi blessé il ya
certains meyrin ge et 18 - les - 18
centimes sur le litre d'essence sert à
rien mais ça sert à rien c'est à dire
que globalement ça coûte très très cher
oui d'accord et globalement voyez
personne le voit enfin oui c'est les
prix contient c'est la psychologie du
consommateur oui quand vous mais le
premier jour d'ios et bien puis après
c'est même pas parce que vous n'avez pas
vu le prix baisser ou sa vie il faut il
faut juste faire un raisonnement
intellectuel les prix auraient augmenté
plus messi avait pas une cela donc voyez
vous le voyez pas trop si vous êtes un
ménage aisé de toute manière vous
j'aurais continué à consommer ça stimule
une consommation alors qu'en fait il
faudrait aujourd'hui arrêter de financer
tout ce qui pollue donc en fait c'est
pas forcément la bonne solution après ce
qu'il ya une meilleure solution à très
court terme ça s'est compliqué est
ménagé leurs
ouïes ça on s'est dit c'est par des
cibles de revenu saas est assez facile
mais aujourd'hui il faut pas aider que
ceux qui ont déménagé qui ont des
revenus modestes c'est plutôt votre
situation est ce que vous êtes urbain
est ce que vous êtes rural ce que vous
êtes active
un peu plus complexe c'est d'ailleurs le
le verbatim change un peu c'est pas les
ménages modestes et les ménages fragiles
et fragilisé par cette crise oui c'est
pas exactement les mêmes et là ça
devient compliqué ça devient compliqué à
combien de kilomètres est-ce que vous
avez une alternative et que c'était ça
devient enfin le gendre une usine à gaz
c'est le risque auquel le gouvernement
est confronté
la mesure non balle elle est injuste et
inefficace et puis mal équipés
allez tout envie de casser le problème
et tout le monde on n'a pas besoin là en
trois mois ça a coûté 4 milliards et
c'est vrai que ce que cherche à faire
l'exécutif c'est ciblées sur ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin les travaux sont en
cours depuis l'automne dernier depuis
des mois à bercy on essaie de recroiser
les fichiers deux cartes grises avec les
déclarations d'impôts de revenu fiscal
on est en train de les remplir en ce
moment ses déclarations donc peut-être
qu'à l'été on aura un croisement de ces
fichiers pour cibler ces aides vers
notamment les travailleurs
plus tôt en campagne qui ont besoin de
fervents 30 kilomètres par jour pour
aller à leur travail cibler les aides à
la pompe sur ces ménages là mais c'est
vrai que c'est très compliqué en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'emmanuel
macron a promis un paquet pouvoir
d'achat dès cet été il y aura un loi de
finances rectificative qui va mettre en
musique plusieurs mesures les aides à la
pompe mais aussi l'augmentation des
fonctionnaires des minima sociaux des
retraités donc on va encore avoir pas
mal de milliards qui vont qui vont être
dépensées fesseur il a vomi bien sûr
mais l'ensemble des fonctionnaires il y
aura des meilleurs des négos qui vont se
mettre en place avec la toute la
fonction publique et le point d'indicé
va être augmenté 1 2 3 milliards on
attend alors entre la dette va donc
s'alourdir encore un peu plus on ouvre
le chapitre dette dans ce dans ce débat
avec jonathan du prix yeahs rebond soir
jonathan la cette dette qui s'étaient
envolés on peut le dire pendant le
quinquennat macron oui tout à fait la
dette française aujourd'hui c'est 2008
134 milliards d'euros ça fait environ
115 % du pib environ 40 de 1000 euros
par français sont vraiment se faire peur
sur cinq ans est bête elle a augmenté de
+ 600 milliards donc c'est une
augmentation on peut imputer notamment à
certaines réformes entreprises par
emmanuel macron notamment la suppression
de l' isf de la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des ménages ou encore pourquoi pas
des certaines réformes fiscales
entreprises pour les entreprises à cela
s'est ajouté l'arrivée du coc vider le
fameux quoi qu'il en coûte un café
s'envoler dette publique on estime à
environ 300 milliards le poids de la
crise sanitaire dans notre dette
actuelle mais pour la sénatrice
christine lagarde qui est ici la vice
présidente de la commission des finances
du sénat l air et bien cette dette c'est
surtout leur en fait la dette pré
existante au co vide qui complique la
donne aujourd'hui
qu'on dit souvent c'est un peu pour
reprendre les propos de christine
lagarde à l'époque c'est que normalement
on répare le toit de sa maison quand il
ya du soleil pour éviter la pluie
ensuite et nous en fait quand il y avait
un peu de soleil un peu de croissance on
n'a pas du tout réparer le toit de notre
maison on a continué à dépenser sans
compter sans rembourser notre passif ce
qui fait qu'on est entré fragile déjà un
peu malade dans la crise de l'aco vide
et là on sort on est complètement au
fond de nos clients
méfiez-vous jonathan vous avez quelques
économistes experts qui vous écoutent
les contrôles à istanbul chance en tout
cas si on regarde l'attitude des
décideurs n'a pas l'impression que grand
monde si attac réellement sans doute
peut-être parce que les taux d'intérêt
auxquels l'état emprunté ont très
fortement baissé durant le quinquennat
passé en moyenne hexagonale emprunter 1
1% est certes un certain taux ont même
avoisiner parfois les 0% alors même que
notre croissance elle avoisine les 2,6
selon l'insee donc le coût de notre
dette est finalement assez bas mais le
risque est finalement à moyen long terme
si les taux d'intérêts justement venait
à remonter si l'état n'arrive pas à
contenir le niveau de sa dette et donc
que ces dépenses restent supérieures à
ses recettes annuelles et ben alors
finalement rembourser cette dette se
fera au détriment d'autres dépenses de
l'état il faudra donc forcément faire
des arbitrages sur des postes clés comme
la santé l'éducation la culture ou
encore pourquoi pas la défense même
c'est pas l'ordre du jour ou pire à la
place de l'exécutif on pourrait même
imaginer remonter les impôts eh ben ça
c'est laid fait partie des mesures les
plus impopulaires qui soit je pensais
merci à jonathan pour ces chiffres et
ces explications anne sophie
elle siffle ça change quoi la hausse des
taux d'intérêt la on assiste depuis
quelques semaines à une hausse des taux
d'intérêt qu'est ce que ça change voilà
avec ses 2800 quelle est celle qui nous
a donné 2008 134 milliards de dettes
alors ça veut dire c'est déjà un signal
fort puisque on a en a plus connu ça
depuis des décennies puis en tout cas la
crise la crise financière c'est surtout
le signal pour les ménages de dire ben
voila vous allez avoir un crédit
immobilier où la vie dans votre
reportage ça va coûter plus cher les
entreprises pareil voulez vous financez
ça va coûter plus cher donc l'argent
l'endettement coûte plus cher et donc de
fait et bien ça a un impact sur
l'anticipation des agents entreprises
ménages et donc on l'a dit on va
épargner on va moins consommer on fait
des arbitrages et donc concrètement ça
permet un ralentissement de l'économie
donc c'est positif puisque le but est de
faire baisser l'inflation c'est quand
même je rappelle le mandat d'aider des
banques centrales on a un peu oublié
mais c'est quand même ça c'est pour ça
qu'elles sont là en premier lieu donc là
on espère que ça va fonctionner et pour
moi la grande difficulté c'est que
justement surtout en europe on a une
inflation qui est énergétique et donc on
n'est pas dans une inflation clastiques
comme honda aux états unis
d'augmentation des salaires sinon j'ai
peur c'est qu'on augmente les taux et
donc de fait on impacte négativement la
reprise économique et qu'on n'est pas
forcément une baisse de l'inflation
significatifs comme se serait attendu
alors je reprend une phrase la france et
au concours j'ai souvent entendu depuis
plusieurs mois à fait le genre de la
france est bien notée on nous paye pour
emprunter ils ce sont les taux négatifs
ça voulait effectivement alors on va pas
rentrer dans cette édition mais ça je
crois je pense que c'est en train de
s'inverser où ça s'est inversé donc je
reviens à la question des 2100 et
quelques milliards de dette est ce
qu'elles vont s qui va forcément nous
coûter beaucoup plus cher alors elle va
nous coûter plus cher c'est une
certitude le signal au niveau
macroéconomique en termes de finances
publiques c'est la fête est finie en
réalité ça fait dix ans les taux
baissent depuis 30 depuis 40 ans même en
réalité depuis les années 80 mais on a
une très forte baisse casse politique
accommodante de la banque centrale
européenne depuis depuis dix ans depuis
le début de l'année enfin 2021 on était
à des taux zéro sur la dette française
on est passé à un ennemi là à peu près
1,5 1,6 et en réalité on est pris en
tenaille par deux événement qui sont
d'un côté cette hausse des taux et de
l'autre la hausse de l'inflation aussi
la hausse des taux juste un chiffre on
va pas sonner tout le monde a sommé tout
le monde mais une hausse de 1% c'est à
peu près deux milliards de charges
supplémentaires 2 milliards d'euros de
charges supplémentaires sur les intérêts
de la dette l'année suivante au bout de
dix ans ces 39 milliards d'euros en plus
chaque année là on n'a pas fait plus ça
on a fait plus un et demi je vous laisse
faire la somme de l'autre côté vous avez
l'inflation 10% environ un dixième de
notre dette est indexé sur l'inflation
environ 300 milliards d'euros et une
hausse de l'inflation d'un point ces
deux milliards est ce que je comprends
ce qui est calculée aujourd'hui à bercy
c'est que c'est surtout l'inflation qui
va nous coûter cher cette année sur la
charge de la dette accord parle
d'environ 8 milliards d'euros de plus
sur cette charge laetitia c'est
intéressant de voir comment emmanuel
macron communique sur la dette ou ne
communique pas à thomas parce que ça a
aidé le sujet tabou de sa campagne il ne
l'a jamais prononcé ce mode est alors
valérie pécresse à tenter de l'amener
dans le débat politique présidentielle
elle n'était forcément pas très audible
a vu la campagne qu'elle a fait après
son zénith et donc emmanuel macron en a
profité pour ne rien dire mais le sujet
a tout de même été abordé par marine le
pen s'est passé aussi un peu sous les
radars je vous propose d'écouter la
réponse d'emmanuel macron c'était
pendant le débat du second tour madame
vous le constaterez en quelques contres
n'a absolument pas répondu sur le
coville j'ai expliqué les 600 milliards
de dettes que c'était ça la dette covin
ses 600 milliards de dette je l'assumé
totalement
voilà ça c'est la réponse d'emmanuel
macron il y ait beaucoup de fact
checking thomas ensuite à la suite de
cette affirmation vraiment qu'ils
ferment du président sortant réélu et
finalement c'était marine le pen qui
avait raison marine le pen estimer
évaluer le coût du coc vide à 165
milliards d'euros et ensuite quand on
regarde par exemple les chiffres de la
cour des comptes la cour des comptes
donne 145 milliards d'euros là où il
faut un peu nuancé quand même le fait
que marine le pen avait raison c'est
qu'il faut ajouter la baisse bien sûr
des recettes publiques due au repli du
pib à cause de la crise pour vider sa on
l'évalué à peu près à 300 milliards
d'euros mais quand même on est loin des
600 milliards affirmer comme ça avec un
aplomb bons qu'ils étaient difficilement
contestable apparemment puisque marine
le pen n'a pas contesté emmanuel macron
donc c'est lui le meilleur sur la
communication sauf que quand on assène
ce type de chiffres ça peut être une
bonne stratégie pour un débat
présidentiel d'ailleurs ça l'a été mais
ensuite pour ce second mandat il me
semble qu'il va devoir quand même faire
un exercice de transparence et expliquer
aux français comment parce que là c'est
une question qui reste encore en suspens
quand je faisais quand je vous écoute
tous comment on rembourse ses dettes in
fine est effectivement une une autre
réaction merci laetitia sur cet
équilibre des finances publiques à
remettre au coeur de nos priorités sel
alors il est là pour ça mais quand même
pierre moscovici qui est premier
président de la cour des comptes il
publie une tribune dans les échos ce
matin et je vais le site et il importera
que la france en assume pleinement les
obligations et replace la question de
l'équilibré de ses finances publiques au
coeur de ses priorités sa crédibilité et
la préservation de sa souveraineté
économique en dépendent eric heyer c'est
c'est ça que je trouve intéressant la
crédibilité de la france sur les marchés
financiers est-ce qu'elle alors on n'est
pas les seuls à avoir beaucoup et s'est
beaucoup endetté mais est ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle peut être mise en péril dans
les prochains mois à cause de ses 2800
milliards de dettes et à cette inversion
logique avec les talkie qui remonte tout
ça est relative cedar par rapport aux
autres pays sans doute pas parce que
quand raphaël dit que l'ailé les taux
d'intérêt n'ont cessé de baisser de 40
ans c'est pas le valable dans tous les
pays européens on a vu que en 2011
notamment la halle est l'intérêt sur
l'italie l'espagne la grèce tous les
pays l'irlande ont tous exploser la
france non donc il ya eu une crédibilité
française qui se rapproche plus de
l'allemagne que des pays du sud ont une
il faut faut aussi un tout petit peu ben
remettre ça au milieu et leur ensuite le
gros problème c'est la vitesse alors un
d'abord c'est à quoi ça a servi voyez je
pense que la communication parce qu'on
parle de communication n'est pas assez
fait sur à quoi ça a servi cette dette
comme ici ça permet de sauver les
entreprises le tissu productif et a
permis de sauver le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et mettre 7 sur épargne c'est ça
qui va nous permettre demain d'avoir une
croissance économique et de rembourser
une partie
s'était d'ailleurs les éléments de
langage
le capital missing qui ont équipe qui
aurait justement manqué sur la lèpre on
l'avait pas fait et donc la crédibilité
de la france dans l'avenir est
relativement enfin on voyait que les
taux d'intérêt augmentent en france mais
partout à peu près au même rythme et il
y avait en france pas plus qu'ailleurs
c'est plutôt l'europe voyez c est la
question des banques centrales notamment
européennes c'est de se dire mais est-ce
qu'il va pas on va pas retourner à
l'épisode de 2010 2011 où les taux
d'intérêt avaient trop fortement
augmenté mais pas en france un trop
fortement augmenté dans les pays
périphériques et notamment dans un grand
pays qui s'appelle l'italie est
aujourd'hui lé taux italiens commencent
à poser problème et donc voyez là je
pense que c'est un autre point de vue
mais moi je moi je lis en tout cas la
proposition de réforme des retraites
pour justement rassurer et donner un gaz
se donnait veulent être un peu de marge
de manoeuvre
actuellement c'est à dire que oui quand
vous dites je vais réduire la dépense
publique en faisant la chasse à la
fraude fiscale personne n'y croit je
quand je vous dit je vais marine le pen
oui mais même là emmanuel macron il ya
dix milliards sur la chaîne
entre nous qu'il essaye s'il y arrive
tant mieux c'est pas très crédible pour
nos partenaires quand on dit qu'on va
supprimer supprimer cent mille
fonctionnaires c'est pas très crédible
c'est un petit montant il n'est pas très
crédible en revanche dès que vous dites
je fais une réforme des retraites que
j'engage à l'horizon et on va monter à
60 4 voire 65 ans là c'est un cap là on
sait que ça rapporte entre 9 et 15
milliards là vous êtes crédible alors
voyez 9,15 milliards on a rappelé
aujourd'hui on dépense 9,15 milliards
tous les quinze jours donc ça va suivre
ça a peut-être pas suffire être
complètement crédible mais tout de même
et c'est le dernier point puisque c'est
relatif les autres pays européens vont
devoir aussi mettre en place des aides
parce que voyez si on est dépendants
nous du pétrole et du gaz russe par
rapport à l'allemagne par rapport à tous
ces pays on n'est pas du tout dépendant
donc du coup les aides et l'inflation
qui est de 4,8 chez nous elle est plutôt
autour de 8 10 dans les autres pays
européens donc je pense que c'est ça qui
va un peu sauvé aussi la crédibilité
française parce que tout ça est relative
et la situation française n'est pas
bonne mais quand on se compare ces
appels toujours important de se comparer
on va terminer avec le marché de
l'immobilier on a on a donné le chiffre
mais je vais le leur prendre c'était un
le taux moyen des emprunts à 20 ans
étaient 1,1 pour cent en janvier on est
à 1,5 aujourd'hui et j'accueille dans ce
débat maël bernier directrice de la
communication de meilleurtaux.com qu'est
ce que vous prévoyez bonsoir bienvenue
qu'est ce que vous payez pour les
prochaines semaines est ce que les taux
devraient continuer d'augmenter
à priori oui parce que on voit très bien
que les banques font ce qu'elles peuvent
pour maintenir des taux le plus bas
possible quand même pour maintenir cette
activité qui reste pour l'instant très
dynamique parce qu'on a des on a des
français qui sont toujours dans cette
recherche de d'acquisition mais il est
vrai que ces fameuses aux athées et les
obligations du trésor qui sont un peu la
référence pour fixer les taux des
crédits aux particuliers
sont passés en l'espace de trois mois de
-0 35 de mémoire en janvier à 1 60
aujourd'hui donc il est bien évident que
les banques peuvent pas continuer à
prêter à 1% avec des taux pareil donc
pour rappel la 1ère fois qu'on a eu des
watts et un ennemi c'était en 2014 et
des taux d'intérêt des crédits aux
particuliers était à 3% donc
oui les taux vont continuer de remonter
encore une fois on voit une augmentation
assez rapide et surtout ce qui est
important de dire c'est sur tous les
profils
oui et avec quelles conséquences sur les
marchés de l'immobilier ça veut dire
quoi des arbitrages on achète des
surfaces plus petites ou alors il faut
plus d'apport personnel voilà ça comment
commence comment vous ça doit être votre
quotidien avec la plupart de vos clients
en ce moment comment ça se passe alors
globalement sous la halle à la hausse
aujourd'hui elle est le passage de un
ennemi ça équivaut pour après moyens à
la à 45 euros de plus donc on n'est pas
encore dans une société c'est une
situation partant complètement critique
il est vrai que ce qui se passe c'est
que vous avez effectivement des gens qui
vont acheter un peu plus petits qui vont
emprunter mois donc acheter plus petits
ceux qui ont la chance comme les et
monsieur taylor d'avoir de l'épargné est
d'avoir beaucoup d pad n'est pas ça n'a
rien changé pour eux parce qu'ils vont
fonctionner un peu de leur épargne pour
acheter des biens immobiliers de leurs
rêves et puis c'est vrai qu'elle est
grosse différence sur les prix de
l'immobilier sur leur évolution en
fonction du type de bien dans les villes
moyennes les maisons avec jardin reste
saint graal et des appartements commence
déjà un peu calé oui il ya toute une
évolution qui va falloir suivre les mois
qui viennent mais qui est pas forcément
flat sur tous les biens immobiliers ça
veut dire je termine avec ça que les
villes moyennes c'était un des effets de
la crise qu vide les villes moyennes
elles attirent toujours les français
aujourd'hui toujours toujours et ces
essais des vies qui sont une espèce de
rattrapage en fait pour certaines qui
étaient très faibles en termes de prix
et aujourd'hui ça remonte un peu mais ça
reste finalement assez accessible et
dans beaucoup de villes moyennes ht
contre le même prix que l'on est donc
même avec des taux à un an et demi ça va
encore largement coup merci beaucoup
merci paris mais si vous les mettez ça
crée pas réaliste
peut pas trop loin à paris voyez ce que
je veux dire alors je vous dis les big
up toute une série de villes hôtes otg
je rappelle des vies tgv qui vont la
couronne le mans reims même livre ou en
fait le prix de location est équivalent
au prix de l'achat anciennement
quasiment laetitia vous avez noté la la
la liste vous allez prendre le tgv à
partir de la saison prochaine
l'immobilier à ce que celle ci s'est on
parlait des moteurs du moteur de
l'économie emparé de la pole à la
consommation c'est un moteur c'est un
moteur essentiel aussi c'est un peu de
la palissade ce que je dis mais à quel
niveau par rapport à d'autres vous voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est un moteur
essentiel et puis surtout c'est un bon
indicateur parce que c'est vrai que
quand on a parlé de la sueur épargnent
ça reste un peu une valeur refuge quand
tout va mal on parle souvent de l'or il
ya aussi le bien immobilier on s'est dit
on investit voilà on a quelque chose de
concret on pourra leur revendre plus
tard donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un côté
valeurs refuges en plus en effet il y
avait quand même une augmentation de l'
épargne sur des revenus qui peuvent être
assez élevé donc tout le monde n'est pas
du tout logé à la même enseigne en scène
ya vraiment une forte inégalité sur sur
l'aspect immobilier et donc avec la
crise a renforcé cela donc c'est une
valeur refuge il va continuer à avoir
des achats par contre en effet ce ne
sont pas les mêmes personnes qui
pourront avoir accès au crédit oui à
fait le genre dont on l'a évoqué raphaël
bernier le design on a encore de la
marge à 1,5 ou 1,6 on est encore loin de
viser voilà souvenez vous il ya dix ans
en arrière on était à 4% c'est on reste
à des niveaux quand même extrêmement bas
et très attractif nos mains ennemies
alesi si vous avez un projet immobilier
c'est le moment d'y aller parce que ça
va monter ça va très probablement mon
entre dans une ère où les taux des
banques centrales vont augmenter les
marchés ont déjà commencé à augmenter
les taux des emprunts souverains et donc
la dynamique ne fait que commencer il
faut bien se dire que avec cette poussée
des taux et de l'inflation on va très
certainement avoir une poussée beaucoup
plus élevés que ceux un point et demi
aux jouets mais eric heyer ça peut ça
peut monter jusqu où un alors enfin
jusqu'où à court terme je peux pas trop
vous le dire mais en fait normalement le
taux normal auquel on devrait y être
c'est l'inflation plus la croissance de
l'économie alors voyez pour l'économie
française la croissance potentielle elle
tourne aux alentours de 1 2 imaginons
que la banque centrale arrive à
maîtriser l'inflation aux alentours de 2
de plus 1,2 égal 3 donc le dos à 5 10
ans il devrait situer aux alentours de 3
d'accord et trois a321 canular à court
terme il est possible que les banques
centrales si elle pense là trop
d'inflation elle désire calmer tout cela
d'un coup et donc pas très tôt au dessus
pour essayer de calmer d'un coup mais ça
on sait pas si elles vont le faire ou si
au contraire devant rester prudente et
être toujours en dessous pour continuer
à stimuler l'activité et donc à jouer
moins sûr sur l'inflation ce qui me
semble être important moi c'est que je
pense que l'inflation va effectivement
revenir un jour ou l'autre c'est à dire
dans deux ans je sais pas aux alentours
de 2% mais que les prix vont rester
élevés voyez l'inflation c'est la
progression des prix on a une très forte
progression des prix les niveaux
aujourd'hui sont élevés ça qu'on va
rester à ces niveaux élevés mais avec
des progressions qui seront plus on va
dire banque centrale compatible aux
alentours de 2 2 nuls mais il faut pas
s'attendre à des baisses de prix oui ça
serait assez étonnant qu'un certain
nombre de prix reviennent parce qu'on
pourrait dire non mais l'inflation est
passée à 8 donc en fait on va revenir à
zéro et sarah une inflation au moins il
a laissé les prix enfin vous pouvez
balle en soit c'est des phénomènes de
bulles alors il est possible que oui si
aujourd'hui on nous considère c'est une
grosse bulle immobilière ou un à notre
prix d'actifs ont les prix d'actifs ça
peut être des bulles et donc si vous
augmentez très vite les taux d'intérêt
vous faites
éclater cette bulle on a déjà connu des
crises alors je pense que aujourd'hui
les banques centrales ne désire pas
faire exploser ses buts parce que c'est
elles qui les ont créés cette fois ci
donc ça serait étonnant que le pyromane
deviennent pompiers puis pyromane parce
que si la bulle explose on va leur
demander de revenir pour elle essaye de
calmer les prix doucement mais ça veut
dire qu'elles vont rester durablement
élevé
il ya deux éléments quand même en france
où la majorité des ménages surendettés
en taux fixe c'est vrai qu'on pour nous
c'est la norme d'avoir un taux fixe mais
dans d'autres pays notamment d'europe du
nord le taux variable est beaucoup plus
développé que c'est pas la même
inquiétude et en est là aujourd'hui donc
même si cdp qui peuvent paraître plus
robuste certains des finances publiques
ça c'est un vrai sujet et donc c'est un
sujet globalement pour la zone euro
parce qu'on n'a pas du tout les mêmes
profils de pays également sur le taux
d'intérêt d'emprunt sur l'immobilier qui
joue et puis l'autre élément assez qu'en
france c'est vrai qu'on en parle
beaucoup de millionnaires etc mais c'est
beaucoup des fortunes immobilières c'est
beaucoup moins on investit beaucoup
moins dans les entreprises même si on
essaie de le faire mais ça ça marche
beaucoup moins donc c'est vrai que c'est
immobiliers si les déprécier bien vous
baissez a vraiment le niveau de richesse
de population tient maël bernier votre
votre témoignage
meilleurtaux.com c'est le effectivement
les taux fixes et quelle part du marché
c'est 100% des marchés on a la même
chose qu'on a vu les taux variables
c'était des taux dix capes et et c'était
en 2013 2014
maintenant les banques ne prêtent plus
qu'à toufik donc et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'il dit c'est une
énorme sécurité notamment pour les
ménages parce que même en empruntant
effectivement à des taux même à 2% ce
qui pourrait être le cas dans les mois
qui viennent avec l'inflation en face
finalement on reste sur des taux très
bas est gravé dans le marbre est ce que
vous voyez quand même les prix baisser
ou est ce qu'il pourrait baisser dans
l'est dans les grandes villes dans les
capitales régionales je pense qu'ils
baissent déjà dans certaines grandes
villes ou en tout cas ils sont en tout
cas globalement stable ils montrent plus
au ciel les primés mais vraiment c'est
vraiment très compliqué de dire parce
qu'il ya des marchés immobiliers même
dans certaines villes dans certaines
régions qui sont très très particulier
bord de mer les villes de l'ouest et
avait vraiment des gros mouvements et
donc c'est très bon billet le dire les
prix baissent ou monde parce qu'il ya
vraiment des grosses différences selon
les villes et les biens et même mené
bien même ville jours et qu'on termine
il nous reste trois minutes pour avec ce
mode incertitudes notamment prononcé par
christine lagarde la présidente de la
banque centrale européenne avec cette
guerre en ukraine c'est l'ère de
l'incertitude qui s'est ouverte on
écoute
la guerre en ukraine affecte gravement
l'économie de la zone euro et a
considérablement accru l'incertitude
l'impact de la guerre sur l'économie
dépendra de l'évolution du conflit
de l'effet des sanctions actuelles et
d'éventuelles mesures supplémentaires
pour cette bourse s'adresse à fait le
genre les chefs d'entreprise aiment pas
beaucoup d'incertitudes par définition
est ce qu est ce que ça se ressent déjà
sur les investissements alors non
étonnamment parce que le coût de la
crise et le coût de l'inflation
notamment a été porté majoritairement
par l'état pour l'instant le plan le
bouclier énergétique segal 26 milliards
d'euros mis sur la table et et l'autre
tiers ce sont les ménages qui le qu'il
le paye les entreprises ont été assez
préservé pour l'instant pas sûr que ça
dure et c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il va
falloir augmenter les salaires aussi
mais l'investissement tient en une
croissance zéro au 1er trimestre
l'investissement des entreprises lui a
continué d'augmenter pendant combien de
temps à voir mais l'emploi tient aussi
c'est une donnée très importante et les
chefs d'entreprise vous savez en réalité
ça fait plus de dix ans maintenant qu'il
qu'il gère à monde de crise on entre
vraiment dans un monde de crise 2008
crise financière suivie par la crise de
la zone euro en france on a eu les
attaques terroristes les gilet jaune
ensuite au niveau international la crise
sanitaire donc en réalité on est sans
cesse en crise depuis le tournant des
années 2000 quasiment et il est très
possible que cela dure en réalité d'où
ce changement total en matière de
finances publiques on ne compte plus les
milliards et dans tous les pays c'est
vrai qu'il faut piloter maintenant au
jour le jour agilité et le maître mot
chez les chefs d'entreprise aujourd'hui
mais alors eric heyer si si la crise
quelle qu'elle soit provoc l'incertitude
et justifie le quoi qu'il en coûte on
n'en sortira jamais vraiment sortira
jamais alors on vous aide avec la
certitude auriez peut-être une routine a
la certitude pourquoi maintenant on sait
qu'on vit dans un monde incertain et
donc ce n'est pas ça qui nous empêche
pour les entreprises c'est ça paraît
assez clair pour les ménages beaucoup
moins dac le ménage lui peut se dire
attention demain il va y avoir des
tensions et donc j'épargne et là sur
épargne que l'on voit et le
l'augmentation de 2,7 et pensait
peut-être nous sommes d'epargne de
précaution qui petit à petit
et même s'il est à dire on sera derrière
vous bah il ya un peu lent même si je
suis pas toujours fan de cette de cette
théorie un peu de faits ricardien c'est
à dire se dire bon attention les
déficits quoi qu'il en coûte évidemment
il va falloir payer donc il va y avoir
des hausses d'impôts demain et donc si
demain il ya des hausses d'impôts il va
falloir j'épargne aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir payer les hausses d'impôts donc
ça c'est pas interdit et ça ça va
dépendre en fait du discours politique
si on commence à dire ben voilà on a un
modèle social qui nous coûte cher il va
falloir faire des réformes de
l'assurance chômage des réformes des
retraites des réformes un peu de tout
son modèle social il est possible que
les ménages l'incertitude passe par là
en disant bon donc je serai moins
protégés demain et donc il va falloir
j'épargne un peu plus aujourd'hui pour
préparer l'avenir si demain je devais
tombe au chômage ou pour préparer ma
retraite merci beaucoup à tous était
passionnant il ya un élément dans
l'équation on n'a pas parlé pourtant il
est majeur c'est la transition
écologique et et tous les secteurs de
l'économie qui sont obligés de se
préparer et de faire parfois muté leurs
modèles bref c'est une période
passionnante mais compliqué aussi pour
les économistes ce que vous êtes et pour
les chefs d'entreprise merci encore
d'être revenu sur sur ce plateau